I was thinking that this is very similar to a Hamiltonian path. And I just looked up what the difference is. So a Hamiltonian path is a path in a graph that visits every vertex exactly once. Whereas an Eulerian path is a path in a graph that visits every edge exactly once. And it's sometimes also called an Eulerian path or an Eulerian walk, and an Eulerian circuit is a Eulerian path that starts and ends at the same node. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 220, recorded on January 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about graph algorithms, the seven bridges of Konigsberg, Hamiltonian paths, Eulerian paths, and more.
我当时在想，这和哈密顿路径非常相似。我刚刚查了一下它们的区别。哈密顿路径是图中访问每个顶点恰好一次的路径。而欧拉路径是图中访问每条边恰好一次的路径。它有时也被称为欧拉路径或欧拉游走，而欧拉回路则是起点和终点相同的欧拉路径。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 220 期，录制于 2025 年 1 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 将讨论图算法、柯尼斯堡七桥问题、哈密顿路径、欧拉路径等内容。
End of episode 219, start of episode 220. So, as I said before, I listened to some of the chapters, and chapter one of this book was What Are Algorithms? And he makes this one other claim that I didn't mention, which is that he says that algorithms must terminate after some finite number of steps, that an algorithm cannot run forever. I'm not sure whether I agree with that. But in general, I like the way that he defines algorithms as an algorithm is a set of steps to do something, and it's a set of steps that you could execute by hand. I'm on board with that. But so chapter two is about graph problems, which is not something we've ever really talked about amongst ourselves. Do you know much about like graph problems? Not really. I mean, there was a point in time back when I was a budding ICPC programmer, and you had to then go and learn all the different shortest path.
第 219 期结束，第 220 期开始。正如我之前所说，我听了其中的一些章节，这本书的第一章是“什么是算法？”。他提出了我之前没提到的另一个观点，即算法必须在有限的步骤后终止，算法不能永远运行。我不确定我是否同意这一点。但总的来说，我喜欢他将算法定义为“执行某项任务的一系列步骤”，而且这些步骤是可以手动执行的。我同意这一点。但第二章是关于图问题的，这不是我们之间真正讨论过的话题。你对图问题了解多吗？不太了解。我的意思是，在我还是个初出茅庐的 ICPC 程序员时，确实有一段时间需要去学习各种最短路径算法。
Yeah. I can't even remember the name of them, but, like, there's the beginner ones that, ooh, let's look it up. I want to say Mistral, but that's the name of an LLM, not the name of a shortest path. Let's go for, actually, let's actually go to an LLM. Because I want to say one of them is like a three letter as well. It's like Kim or Kip or something like that. List me just the names of 20 very common graph algorithms. Obviously, Dijkstra and ASTAR
是的。我甚至记不住它们的名字，但比如那些入门级的，哦，让我们查一下。我想说是 Mistral，但那是大语言模型（LLM）的名字，不是最短路径算法的名字。让我们去问问大语言模型吧。因为我想其中一个名字也是三个字母的。比如 Kim 或 Kip 之类的。请列出 20 个非常常见的图算法。显然，Dijkstra 和 A* 算法肯定在内。
but I want, I think they're called like spanning something like that, common graph I do believe that this chapter covers it's got a section on shortest path and I believe it covers the Dijkstra algorithm Yeah, Prim was the so I'll just read out
但我认为它们被称为生成树之类的，常见的图算法。我相信这一章涵盖了它，里面有一节关于最短路径的内容，我相信它涵盖了 Dijkstra 算法。是的，Prim 算法也是，所以我直接读出来吧。
the 20 that were on chat GPT. Am I on 01? I know they give you like a couple of 01 for free. And I think this is my first. It's 10 a.m. on a Wednesday. You know what I've used my 01s for? Travel planning. I was about to say travel planning.
ChatGPT 上列出的那 20 个。我是在用 o1 模型吗？我知道他们免费提供几次 o1 的使用机会。我想这是我第一次用。现在是周三上午 10 点。你知道我把 o1 用在什么地方了吗？旅行规划。我正想说旅行规划。
It's very good. Do you know that through Perplexity AI we have 01? Oh, I did not know that. Yeah. You got to just register, email them. By we here, Connor means we in video. Yeah, yeah. I was about to explain to the listener.
这非常有用。你知道通过 Perplexity AI 我们有 o1 吗？哦，我不知道。是的，你只需要注册并给他们发邮件。这里说的“我们”，Connor 指的是我们公司内部。是的，是的。我正准备向听众解释一下。
This is what do they call it? Inside baseball talk. I think I'm not actually sure for how long, but Perplexity AI, which is a search engine, which gives you all the top models. Let's actually go. We're taking a tangent, folks. First time ever on ADSP, the podcast. And you can either. Our first tangent ever.
这叫什么来着？业内行话。我其实不太确定持续了多久，但 Perplexity AI，一个搜索引擎，提供了所有顶级模型。让我们去看看。各位，我们跑题了。这是 ADSP 播客史上第一次。你可以设置它，或者……我们第一次跑题。
Yeah. First tangent ever. You can either set it so that it says default, which is optimized for fast search. And I think then it dispatches to any one of the models that it currently supports. And or you can hard code it to the one that you want. So currently, I have mine hard coded to 01. But they also give you access to cloud 3.5. Sonnet, Sonar Large, GPT-40, Sonar Huge, Grok 2, and Cloud 3.5 Haikyuu. And I just became self-conscious of the way that I'm saying. Is it cloud or is it clawed?
是的，第一次跑题。你可以将其设置为“默认”，即针对快速搜索进行优化。我想它会分发给它当前支持的任何模型。或者你可以将其硬编码为你想要的那个。目前，我把它硬编码为 o1。但他们也让你访问 Claude 3.5 Sonnet、Sonar Large、GPT-4o、Sonar Huge、Grok 2 和 Claude 3.5 Haiku。我刚才对自己发音的方式感到有点不自在。是叫 Cloud 还是 Clawed？
We don't know now. Anyways, forgive me, internet, for potentially mispronouncing cloud. And it's actually pretty phenomenal. Like, the stuff that I'm able to do now, half the time, if I'm doing personal stuff, I'll just give it a whole script and I'll just be like, I need you to make these changes. And it goes and does it and it works and it's fantastic. Anyways, Perplexity AI, I guess that's a, you know, if you are quote unquote sponsoring a company where some of the employees at that company may have podcasts, you may end up getting a free plug.
我们现在也不知道了。总之，请原谅我，互联网，因为我可能把 Claude 的发音弄错了。它实际上非常出色。比如，我现在能做的事情，有一半时间，如果我在处理个人事务，我会直接给它一个完整的脚本，然后说：“我需要你做这些修改。”它就会去执行，而且效果很好，太棒了。总之，Perplexity AI，我想如果你是在“赞助”一家公司，而该公司的一些员工可能拥有播客，你最终可能会得到免费的宣传。
I don't know how much it costs because we get it for free for, I think, a number of months. Currently, it's still letting me log in. So anyways, I also have ChatGPT, though, because ChatGPT gives you faster responses. So if it's something that I know that whatever the free model is, we'll do okay with, such as listing me a list of 20 things that doesn't actually need to be correct. We just go to it for that.
我不知道它要多少钱，因为我们免费用了几个月。目前它仍然让我登录。总之，我也有 ChatGPT，因为 ChatGPT 的响应速度更快。所以如果我知道任何免费模型都能处理得好的任务，比如列出 20 个不需要非常精确的东西，我们就会用它。
And we go to perplexity AI if we're willing to wait five seconds for a response, which is quite a bit. Anyways, top 20 algorithms brought to you by ChatGPT. Could be 01, could be whatever the free tier is. Number one, actually, do you want to play a game? You want to see how many you can guess? Oh, of the top uh graph algorithms i'll give you if you can get five because i technically already said that number six was prims that was the three letter one which actually turned out to be four
如果我们愿意等五秒钟得到响应，我们就会用 Perplexity AI，这其实也挺快的。总之，由 ChatGPT 为您带来的前 20 大算法。可能是 o1，也可能是免费版。第一名，其实，你想玩个游戏吗？你想看看你能猜出多少个吗？哦，在前几大图算法中，如果你能猜出五个，我就给你算赢，因为我刚才已经说了第六个是 Prim 算法，那个三个字母的，结果发现是四个字母的。
letter four letters oh there's it actually and actually you think think of very generic like not even named after someone or with a special name like Like number one and number two, you definitely know. The question is whether you will think of it. It's more of like a category of algorithms. Well, there's probably connectivity or like connected components. It's probably somewhere on there. You're thinking too specific. Okay.
四个字母，哦，确实。而且，想想非常通用的，甚至不是以某人名字命名或有特殊名称的，比如第一名和第二名，你肯定知道。问题是你是否能想到。它更像是一类算法。嗯，可能有连通性或连通分量。它可能就在列表里的某个地方。你想得太具体了。好吧。
You definitely learned this in school. Like everybody learns this as the two broad categories of graph algorithm breath first depth first yeah so depth dfs is number one bfs is number two and then we'll just go down the list full points for bryce it's gonna be like the shortest path um yeah dykstra's is number three number four is bellman ford five is floyd warshall six prim, Prims. Seven, Kruskal. Eight, A-Star. Nine, Johnson's. Ten, Tarjan's algorithm for strongly connected components. I said connected components.
你肯定在学校里学过这个。每个人都把这作为图算法的两大类：广度优先搜索（BFS）和深度优先搜索（DFS）。是的，所以 DFS 是第一名，BFS 是第二名，然后我们顺着列表往下看。Bryce 得满分。接下来应该是最短路径……是的，Dijkstra 是第三名，第四名是 Bellman-Ford，第五名是 Floyd-Warshall，第六名是 Prim 算法，第七名是 Kruskal 算法，第八名是 A* 算法，第九名是 Johnson 算法，第十名是 Tarjan 强连通分量算法。我刚才说了连通分量。
That counts. Eleven is Kosaraju's algorithm also for strongly connected components. Twelve, topological sorting. Thirteen, Edmund's CARP algorithm for maximum flow. Four, Edmunds-Karp algorithm for maximum flow. 14, Ford-Fulkerson algorithm for maximum flow. 15, we're going to mispronounce this one. It could be, we're going to say Dinnich, D-I-N-I-C algorithm for maximum flow.
那算对。第十一名是 Kosaraju 强连通分量算法。第十二名是拓扑排序。第十三名是 Edmonds-Karp 最大流算法。第十四名是 Ford-Fulkerson 最大流算法。第十五名，我们要读错这个名字了。可能是，我们读作 Dinic，D-I-N-I-C 最大流算法。
16, I'm going to mispronounce this one too. It's getting rough, folks. Heer-Holzer algorithm for, or actually I'm guessing because it's named after Euler, it's going to be pronounced Eulerian circuits. Yes, that's actually, we're just about to talk about the Eulerian circuits. That's one of the... 17 is Flurry's algorithm for an Eulerian path. 18 is the Chu-Liu slash Edmunds algorithm for minimum spanning arborescence. 19 is
第十六名，我也要读错这个名字了。各位，情况变得棘手了。Hierholzer 算法，或者其实我猜因为它是以欧拉命名的，所以发音应该是欧拉回路。是的，那其实……我们正要讨论欧拉回路。那是其中之一……第十七名是 Fleury 欧拉路径算法。第十八名是 Chu-Liu/Edmonds 最小生成树形图算法。第十九名是
Kahn's algorithm for topological sorting. And 20, thanks for staying with us listener, Warshall's algorithm for transitive closure. And Prim's was the one I was thinking of. I think Kruskal. But here, let's ask one follow-up question.
Kahn 拓扑排序算法。第二十名，感谢听众朋友们的坚持，Warshall 传递闭包算法。Prim 算法就是我刚才想到的那个。我想还有 Kruskal。但这里，让我们问一个后续问题。
What is Prims' algorithm? It's minimum spanning trees. I was going to say minimum spanning tree. An example of. I knew the word spanning was in it. I remember that from school. So I got into the memorizing of these algorithms at a certain point in time. I think I got through all of the MSTs.
什么是 Prim 算法？它是最小生成树。我正想说最小生成树。一个例子。我知道“生成”这个词在里面。我记得在学校学过。所以我在某个时间点开始死记硬背这些算法。我想我把所有的最小生成树算法都过了一遍。
And then I think, you know, Dijkstra, ASTARS, those are all pretty straightforward. But then I didn't get to, I mean, Floyd Warshall. I think I programmed once. I don't remember what the algorithm is. But all of these like hyphenated names, that's why I kind of like fell out of love with icpc is that like you know intelligence and intuitive thinking works up to a point and then like you just need to start memorizing these hyphenated named algorithms for like specific things which uh didn't really i didn't really fancy that didn't really fancy that anyways over to you now let's talk about
然后我想，你知道，Dijkstra、A*，这些都相当直观。但我没学到……我的意思是，Floyd-Warshall。我想我编程时用过一次。我不记得算法具体是什么了。但所有这些带连字符的名字，这就是我为什么有点不喜欢 ICPC 的原因，因为你知道，智力和直觉思维在一定程度上是有用的，然后你就必须开始死记硬背这些带连字符的算法来处理特定的事情，这我不太喜欢，不太喜欢。总之，现在交给你，让我们谈谈
your larian circuits because that's where this book opens up on. And I had a flashback to my college years. It's pronounced Euler. And I used to pronounce it Euler and then I got raked in the YouTube comments. It's pronounced Euler. So I believe that means that it's an Eulerian. Unless if they change the pronunciation of Euler's name. We can go with Eulerian.
你的欧拉回路，因为这本书就是从这里开始的。我回想起了我的大学时光。它的发音是 Euler（欧拉）。我过去常读作 Euler，然后在 YouTube 评论区被喷了。它的发音是 Euler。所以我相信这意味着它是欧拉的（Eulerian）。除非他们改变了 Euler 这个名字的发音。我们可以用欧拉（Eulerian）这个词。
Come at us, Internet, if it's wrong. So I remember this example from school. Are you familiar with the seven bridges of Konigsberg? Not Kongsberg in Norway, where we've been. Norway. Konigsberg. I have not been. Only you have been to Tech Town.
如果错了，互联网请来纠正我们。所以我记得学校里的这个例子。你熟悉柯尼斯堡七桥问题吗？不是挪威的康斯伯格（Kongsberg），我们去过那里。挪威。柯尼斯堡（Konigsberg）。我没去过。只有你去过科技城。
Oh, okay. All right. Fair enough. I am familiar with the graphic, but I think it's just you need to cross all seven is the problem. So it's, is it, yeah, it's seven bridges. You should go, we'll put a link in the show notes, but you should go look at the bridges. And there, I put a's two islands, and then there's two mainland portions of the city. There's to, I presume, the north and south.
哦，好吧。没关系。我熟悉这个图，但我认为问题就在于你需要穿过所有七座桥。所以，是七座桥。你应该去看看，我们会在节目说明中放一个链接，你应该去看看那些桥。那里有两个岛，然后城市有两个大陆部分。我想，北边和南边各有一个。
And the question is, can you visit all of the bridges and all of the islands without crossing a bridge twice twice yeah and I'll save you and the listener the the entire lesson
问题是，你能不能在不重复经过同一座桥的情况下，走遍所有的桥和所有的岛？是的，我会为你和听众省去整个课程。
but basically this for some reason, this became a mathematical challenge in the 1700s, I guess, to spur the citizens, the local citizens, to think more deeply about math. And Euler came up with a solution, and his solution is that the answer is that no, you cannot do that. And if you look at this as a graph, if you form a graph from the two islands and the two mainland regions, you'll see that every node has an odd number of connections to all the other nodes. And so because of that, that means that you can't visit every bridge, right? That if one of the nodes of this graph has three connections to it,
但基本上，出于某种原因，这在 1700 年代成为了一项数学挑战，我想是为了激励市民，当地市民，更深入地思考数学。欧拉提出了一个解决方案，他的结论是答案为否，你做不到。如果你把这看作一个图，如果你从两个岛和两个大陆区域形成一个图，你会发现每个节点与其他节点的连接数都是奇数。正因为如此，这意味着你无法走遍每一座桥，对吧？如果这个图的一个节点有三条连接，
if it had two connections to it from somewhere else, two edges to it, you know, if it had two connections to it from somewhere else, two edges to it, then you could go visit it over one edge and come back over the other edge. But if it's got three or if it has any odd number, then you're going to always be left either unable to visit that last one or you'd visit that last one and then you would need to go back on a bridge that you've already taken. Does that make sense? Sort of the intuition there? I think so, yeah. I was thinking that this is very similar to a Hamiltonian path and I just looked up what the difference is. So a Hamiltonian path is a path in a graph that visits every vertex exactly once. Yeah.
如果它从其他地方有两条连接，两条边连向它，你知道，如果它从其他地方有两条连接，两条边连向它，那么你可以通过一条边访问它，然后通过另一条边回来。但如果它有三条，或者任何奇数条连接，那么你总是会要么无法访问最后一条边，要么你访问了最后一条边，然后你需要走回你已经走过的桥。这有意义吗？直觉上是这样吗？我想是的。我当时在想，这和哈密顿路径非常相似，我刚刚查了一下它们的区别。所以哈密顿路径是图中访问每个顶点恰好一次的路径。是的。
Whereas an Eulerian path is a path in a graph that visits every edge exactly once. And it's sometimes also called an Eulerian path or an Eulerian walk. And an Eulerian circuit is a Eulerian path that starts and ends at the same node. It's called an Eulerian circuit or an Eulerian tor. What was your although? Well, no, I'm just trying. I always thought that Hamiltonian paths weren't allowed to visit edges more than once. I think it may be that they can't visit an edge more than once but they
而欧拉路径是图中访问每条边恰好一次的路径。它有时也被称为欧拉路径或欧拉游走。而欧拉回路是起点和终点相同的欧拉路径。它被称为欧拉回路或欧拉环。你的那个……虽然……好吧，不，我只是在尝试。我一直以为哈密顿路径不允许访问边超过一次。我想可能是它们不能访问一条边超过一次，但它们
don't have to necessarily visit every edge oh yes yes yes yes yes because i was gonna think by definition if you have like um if you visited an edge more than once you're gonna inevitably end up at a vertex more than once and i i think that i think that an Eulerian path, you just have to visit all the edges exactly once. You don't necessarily, you can visit the same node multiple times. Yes, yeah. That's the distinction. Oh, that Hamiltonian is visiting each vertex exactly once and Eulerian is visiting each edge exactly once. It's interesting because I definitely know that in my programming, competitive programming days that I've solved Hamiltonian path problems. And I'm pretty sure the problem even stated that it was a Hamiltonian path problem.
不一定非要访问每一条边。哦，是的，是的，是的，是的，因为我本来想说，根据定义，如果你访问了一条边超过一次，你不可避免地会多次到达同一个顶点。而且我认为欧拉路径，你只需要访问所有边恰好一次。你不一定……你可以多次访问同一个节点。是的，是的。这就是区别。哦，哈密顿路径是访问每个顶点恰好一次，而欧拉路径是访问每条边恰好一次。这很有趣，因为我肯定知道在我的编程竞赛生涯中，我解决过哈密顿路径问题。而且我很确定题目甚至说明了它是哈密顿路径问题。
But I've never come across Eulerian paths. Maybe it was implicit in the problem, but I've never come across the word, which is surprising considering that it is the sibling concept to Hamiltonian. Yeah. So then these are called either paths or walks, and
但我从未遇到过欧拉路径。也许它隐含在题目中，但我从未见过这个词，考虑到它是哈密顿路径的姊妹概念，这很令人惊讶。是的。所以这些被称为路径或游走，
when you have a path or a walk that starts or ends at the same vertex, it's called a tor or a circuit. So, anyways, a little bit later in the chapter, it starts talking about cycles and graphs and graphs without cycles and the importance of DAGs. And that's when I – I was going to say, are we going to say DAG, directed acyclic graph? Yeah.
当你有一个起点和终点相同的路径或游走时，它被称为环或回路。总之，在这一章的后面，它开始讨论图中的循环、没有循环的图以及有向无环图（DAG）的重要性。那时我……我正想说，我们要说 DAG，即有向无环图吗？是的。
Woo! It's everybody's favorite word or acronym. That's when I pulled out EOP because for some reason it just reminded me of, well, I guess it's not shocking, but it reminded me of this part of EOP where we're stepping up talks about orbits. Are you familiar of this part of EOP where we're stepping up talks about orbits. Are you familiar with this part of EOP? I think it's like the second chapter. Nope.
呜！这是每个人最喜欢的词或缩写。这就是我拿出《EOP》（Elements of Programming）的原因，因为出于某种原因，它让我想起了——好吧，我想这并不令人震惊——但它让我想起了《EOP》中我们开始讨论轨道（orbits）的那部分。你熟悉《EOP》中讨论轨道的这部分吗？我想大概是在第二章。不。
I don't think I ever got past. I'm not even sure if I got past the first chapter. But wait, hold that thought. I'm going to get a beverage. I'll be back in two seconds. Oh, that was quick. That was actually two seconds. All right.
我想我从来没读完过。我甚至不确定我是否读完了第一章。但等等，先别说这个。我去拿杯饮料。两秒钟就回来。哦，真快。真的只有两秒钟。好了。
Orbits, EOP, go. Chapter two, apparently. All right. Orbits EOP. Go. Chapter two, apparently. Well, how many chapters did Zach say we're supposed to read? Because I thought I had read, I think maybe it's just the first chapter. He said like the first chapter is like 80% of the value. So maybe I didn't make it to chapter two. So chapter two, and I've always thought that it's an interesting topic for chapter two. Chapter two talks about transformations and their orbits. And when it says transformations, it's not, I think, the type of transformation that you would think, which would, when I say transformation in the context of Stepanov, what do you think? To transform? Right. Which is taking a function and applying it to all elements of some sequence.
轨道，EOP，开始。显然是第二章。好了。轨道，EOP。开始。显然是第二章。好吧，Zach说我们要读多少章？因为我以为我读过，我想可能只是第一章。他说第一章大概占了80%的价值。所以也许我没读到第二章。所以第二章，我一直认为这是第二章的一个有趣话题。第二章讨论的是变换（transformations）及其轨道。当它说变换时，我想，那并不是你所认为的那种变换，当我提到Stepanov语境下的变换时，你会想到什么？去变换？对吧。也就是取一个函数并将其应用于某个序列的所有元素。
What every other language, actually not every, what almost every other language calls map. Some languages call it each. My guess is that maybe Stepanov would also call it math because when he talks about transformations in EOP, that's not what he means. In EOP, a transformation is taking a function, a function that's a homogeneous function. So it's a function that on some particular type T where it takes in a single T and it produces a single T. And a transformation is what happens when you take one of these functions and you apply it repetitively in succession. So like you do like, you know, f of f of f of f of f of x
其他每种语言，其实不是每种，几乎每种其他语言都称之为map。有些语言称之为each。我猜也许Stepanov也会称之为map，因为当他在《EOP》中谈论变换时，他指的并不是那个。在《EOP》中，变换是指取一个函数，一个同构函数。所以它是一个在某种特定类型T上的函数，它接收一个T并产生一个T。而变换就是当你取这些函数之一并重复、连续地应用它时所发生的事情。就像你做，你知道，f(f(f(f(f(x)))))
or f to the nth power of x. Make sense? Yep. And so like in the case of if your operation is multiplication, then literally taking the nth transformation would be taking the number to its nth power. And if your operation is sum,
或者f的n次方x。明白吗？是的。所以，如果你的操作是乘法，那么字面上取第n次变换就是取这个数的n次方。如果你的操作是加法，
then taking it to the inf uh uh transformation would be uh multiplying the number by you know n times um and uh so that's the notion of transformations and then he talks about orbits. And an orbit is a structure to a transformation. So a transformation has an orbit. Let me see if I can get this right. Its orbits are the elements that are reachable from a starting element by repeated application of the transformation. So, y is reachable from x under um so like if you can if by it makes sense by calling f of you know repeatedly on x if you can get to y then uh uh that's an orbit um so for for well well actually here's a quick question does this transformation only apply to binary operations,
那么取它的第n次变换就是把这个数乘以n次。嗯，这就是变换的概念，然后他谈到了轨道。轨道是变换的一种结构。所以变换有一个轨道。让我看看我能不能说对。它的轨道是从起始元素通过重复应用变换可以到达的元素。所以，y在x下是可达的，嗯，就像如果你通过反复调用f(x)可以到达y，那么这就是一个轨道。嗯，那么，这里有个快速问题，这个变换只适用于二元运算吗？
or is this also applicable to unary operations? So, like, in the examples you use, like the transformation of repeated pluses leads you to multiplication, the transformation of repeated multiplies leads you to power. Those are two different binary operations that lead to a different binary operation. Is the same concept applicable to the plus one function, a partially applied binary operation, which is a different binary operation, is the same concept applicable to the plus one function, a partially applied binary operation, which is a unary operation,
还是这也适用于一元运算？所以，就像你使用的例子，重复加法的变换导致了乘法，重复乘法的变换导致了幂运算。那是两个不同的二元运算，导致了不同的二元运算。同样的概念是否适用于加一函数，一个部分应用的二元运算，这是一个不同的二元运算，同样的概念是否适用于加一函数，一个部分应用的二元运算，这是一个一元运算，
in which case, if you're starting from any value, plus one will get you to all the integer values. All right, technically, if you're starting at one, then it's technically natural numbers. So he, when he's talking about transformations, he talks about, he says that it can be applied to in-area operations, but that mostly we care about unary and binary. So I think it's meant to be applicable to both unary and binary. Although he defines transformations as being something on a unary function. So my examples of addition and multiplication may have been poor ones. I guess what he means when he talks about,
在这种情况下，如果你从任何值开始，加一会带你到达所有的整数值。好吧，严格来说，如果你从1开始，那么严格来说就是自然数。所以他，当他谈论变换时，他谈论的是，他说它可以应用于n元运算，但我们主要关心的是一元和二元。所以我认为它旨在适用于一元和二元。尽管他将变换定义为作用于一元函数的东西。所以我关于加法和乘法的例子可能不太好。我想当他谈论时，他指的是，
he gives sum and product as examples here. The transformation of sum or product would mean like f of x would be x plus x or x times x. So it'd be a unary operation, not a binary operation. I see. Makes sense. In which case, what I said before about it, about what you get out of sum, it wouldn't be multiplication, right? Because f of x, if it's sum, would be... So I think this is classically... Ben and I chat about this all the time,
他在这里给出了加法和乘法作为例子。加法或乘法的变换意味着f(x)将是x+x或x*x。所以它将是一个一元运算，而不是二元运算。我明白了。有道理。在这种情况下，我之前说的关于加法得到的结果，那不会是乘法，对吧？因为f(x)，如果是加法，那将是……所以我认为这是经典的……Ben和我经常聊这个，
that Haskell has this function called iterate, which is the repeated application of a unary function to a starting value. And IOTA is a specialization of this, where IOTA's unary function is plus one. And you give it a starting value, and then it just generates you a sequence of however many times you want to apply that function. But you can generalize this to any unary operation if you want to create all the powers of two you can create a yeah multiply by two unary function and just start with one and then you end up with one two four eight sixteen etc exactly uh and this concept is called different things in different languages but uh i think yeah and haskell is called iterate and that's where we
Haskell有一个函数叫iterate，它是将一元函数重复应用于起始值。IOTA是这个函数的一种特例，其中IOTA的一元函数是加一。你给它一个起始值，然后它就会为你生成一个序列，你想应用多少次该函数都可以。但如果你想创建所有的2的幂，你可以将其推广到任何一元运算，你可以创建一个乘以2的一元函数，从1开始，然后你最终会得到1、2、4、8、16等等，完全正确。嗯，这个概念在不同的语言中有不同的称呼，但我认为，是的，在Haskell中它被称为iterate，这就是我们
will which is interesting because iterate is is – it's an interesting name. Stepinov calls it Transform. Haskell calls it Iterate. Huh. Yes, I think that's exactly the same idea. But, yes, some of what I said before may have been not quite correct. But it's certainly – when he's talking about it here, he means it as a unary operation, a unary power operation.
会提到的，这很有趣，因为iterate是一个有趣的名字。Stepanov称之为Transform。Haskell称之为Iterate。哈。是的，我认为这完全是同一个想法。但是，是的，我之前说的一些话可能不太准确。但可以肯定的是，当他在这里谈论它时，他指的是一元运算，一元幂运算。
So we explained what orbits are. And then there's a notion of an orbit can cyclic if there is some n such that x equals f of n of x. So if at some n, some number of applications of your function, you get back the original x, then you've got a cycle. Yeah, makes sense. The easiest thing you could think of is modify your plus one unary operation with another unary operation of modulus 10. Right.
所以我们解释了什么是轨道。然后有一个概念，如果存在某个n使得x等于f的n次方x，那么轨道可以是循环的。所以如果在某个n，即你的函数的某个应用次数，你回到了原始的x，那么你就有一个循环。是的，有道理。你能想到的最简单的事情就是用模10的另一个一元运算来修改你的加一一元运算。对吧。
So if you start at zero, you'll go up to nine. And then when you hit 10, you'll shoot back down to zero, which is obviously cyclic. And then there's also a notion of terminal transformations, which is it's terminal if at some point you reach an element that is not in the domain. So at some point the sequence ends. And so if it's not terminal and not cyclic, then it's infinite. So he defines four different types of shapes. The first is infinite if there's no cyclic or terminal elements.
所以如果你从0开始，你会一直加到9。然后当你达到10时，你会跳回到0，这显然是循环的。然后还有一个终端变换的概念，如果某一点你到达了一个不在定义域内的元素，它就是终端的。所以序列在某一点结束。因此，如果它既不是终端的也不是循环的，那么它就是无限的。所以他定义了四种不同类型的形状。第一种是无限的，如果没有循环或终端元素。
Then there's terminating, which is if it has a terminal element. And then it's circular if it's cyclic, and then it is p-shaped if x is not cyclic, but its orbit contains a cyclic element. So think about the p as like there's some starting sequence that you never repeat, but then you start at like zero and then you go to five. And then there's a cycle from like five to ten. Make sense? Like if you start iterating the orbit and then eventually you enter a cycle. So you won't repeat everything, but you eventually could go into a cycle and that's what p-shaped should be okay does that make sense
然后是终止的，如果它有一个终端元素。然后是圆形的，如果它是循环的，然后是P形的，如果x不是循环的，但它的轨道包含一个循环元素。所以把P想象成，有一些起始序列你永远不会重复，但你从0开始，然后你走到5。然后从5到10有一个循环。有道理吗？就像如果你开始迭代轨道，最终你进入了一个循环。所以你不会重复所有东西，但你最终可能会进入一个循环，这就是P形，好的，这有道理吗？
there's a yeah there's there are diagrams hopefully very nice very nice and um and uh then he talks about some algorithms for determining the cyclic structure, determining where the collision points would be, where the collision point is a point at which you have two different numbers of invocations that give you the same value. So basically, this is how you detect cycles or the length of a cycle. So it's like, you know, if there's, is there some F to the nth power that is equal to some F to the, you know, nth power? Or he says F to the 2n plus 1 power. And then he goes into some algorithms for measuring, for finding collision points and for measuring the size of orbits. And it's a very interesting part of the book and it comes up in a couple later parts of the book. I think it also comes up in the bifurcate coordinates section, which is chapter 18, which I know well because when I was in college, I did an independent study class with Hartman where we – no, sorry.
有，有图表，希望非常清晰，非常清晰。然后他谈到了一些用于确定循环结构、确定碰撞点在哪里的算法，其中碰撞点是你通过两次不同次数的调用得到相同值的点。所以基本上，这就是你如何检测循环或循环长度的方法。所以就像，你知道，是否存在某个f的n次方等于某个f的，你知道，2n+1次方？然后他深入研究了一些用于寻找碰撞点和测量轨道大小的算法。这是书中非常有趣的一部分，在书的后面部分也出现过几次。我想它也出现在分叉坐标部分，也就是第18章，我很熟悉，因为我在大学时，和Hartman做过一个独立学习课程，我们——不，抱歉。
Chapter 7 is coordinate structures, and I did an independent study class with Hartman where we focused on coordinate structures. And that's what made me remember some of these algorithms. But I was thinking about this notion of transformations and orbits and cycles and whether there's any relation to graph algorithms and cycles and cycle detection and graph algorithms. And I don't really know what the applications of this field of transformations and orbits is. I imagine that random number generators and things like generation functions like IOTA, et cetera,
第7章是坐标结构，我和Hartman做过一个独立学习课程，我们专注于坐标结构。这就是让我记住其中一些算法的原因。但我一直在思考这个变换、轨道和循环的概念，以及它是否与图算法、循环和循环检测以及图算法有任何关系。我真的不知道这个变换和轨道领域的应用是什么。我想随机数生成器和像生成函数（如IOTA等）之类的事情，
are one such case. But I don't know what the other applications would be. But reading this first book, this algorithms book, got me thinking about whether this part of EOP has some relation to graph algorithms. Well, this is just another reminder that I need to go read EOP to have something to say here. I mean, this is technically part three of this conversation, which is not going to come out before next Monday, but I may. It is penciled in, although I probably should have announced it by now. It is penciled in that potentially the first meetup for the from mathematics to generic programming book. I'm reviving the programming languages virtual meetup, which has been dormant for over a year. Technically, Leslie was running it for, I want to say, a year, year and a half while I was taking a break.
就是这样的一个例子。但我不知道还有什么其他应用。但读这第一本书，这本算法书，让我开始思考《EOP》的这一部分是否与图算法有某种关系。好吧，这只是另一个提醒，我需要去读《EOP》才能在这里说点什么。我的意思是，这在技术上是这次对话的第三部分，它不会在下周一之前发布，但我可能会。它已经排上日程了，尽管我可能早就应该宣布了。它已经排上日程了，可能《从数学到泛型编程》（From Mathematics to Generic Programming）这本书的第一次聚会。我正在复兴编程语言虚拟聚会，它已经沉寂了一年多了。技术上讲，Leslie运行了一年，我想说，一年半，当时我正在休息。
Anyways, and that is the sibling book to EOP. But yeah, I mean, it definitely sounds like there's definitely some, what do you call it, similarities between those two things. Do you have like further thoughts other than when you were reading the algorithm or the graph chapter that it was making you think of EOP? And that's what led you to reaching for it? That's sort of the reach. That's sort of the point where my reading reached that I was like, hmm, I remember this section of EOP and maybe it's got some relevance. Yeah, that was pretty much it i i mean i suppose i i'm just curious as to what the application of these stepanov transformations and orbits are like why why is this chapter two in his book um and i know it comes up in some of the later chapters um and maybe maybe that's the answer and I just need to reread the whole book. But yeah.
无论如何，那是《EOP》的姊妹书。但是，是的，我的意思是，听起来确实有，你称之为什么，这两者之间的相似之处。除了你在读算法或图章节时，它让你想到《EOP》之外，你还有其他想法吗？这就是导致你伸手去拿它的原因？这算是那种触及。这算是我的阅读触及到的点，当时我就想，嗯，我记得《EOP》的这一部分，也许它有某种相关性。是的，基本上就是这样。我的意思是，我只是好奇这些Stepanov变换和轨道的应用是什么，为什么这是他书中的第二章，我知道它在后面的一些章节中出现过，也许，也许这就是答案，我只需要重读整本书。但是，是的。
I guess the thing that but the thing is that when he talks about detecting cycles and measuring the length of cycles he's talking about it on not on sequences or on graphs, but he's talking about it on one of these transformations, which is just a function that you call on, you know, one particular and I mean that's useful but is that something that can generalize
我想，当他谈论检测循环和测量循环长度时，他不是在序列或图上谈论它，而是在这些变换之一上谈论它，这只是一个你调用的函数，你知道，一个特定的，我的意思是这很有用，但这是否是可以推广的东西？
to like I have a graph or I have some not just like a function but like I have some data you know some structure some data structure I think that's usually where we want to do cycle detection is some structured data, not on a function itself.
比如我有一个图，或者我不只是像一个函数，而是我有一些数据，你知道，某种结构，某种数据结构，我认为这通常是我们想要进行循环检测的地方，是在某种结构化数据上，而不是在函数本身上。
And so really, that's the question that I had when I was reading the other book was that I'd remembered this part of the Stepanov book talking about about these techniques for finding cycles and classifying the shape and structure of applying a unary function to some, a homogeneous unary function to some input. And I'd never thought before that, huh, maybe that generalizes to finding cycles in data structures or things like that. And I'm not sure that it does, but maybe it does. Yeah, maybe. it does yeah maybe that may maybe if maybe if you have an algorithm to detect a cycle and some you know uh uh like function f of x like imagine that i'm trying to detect like find a cycle like in a list maybe my function could just be uh you know like advanced to the next element in the list?
所以，这确实是我在读另一本书时提出的问题，我记得Stepanov书的这一部分谈到了这些寻找循环和分类形状以及应用一元函数到某种输入（同构一元函数）的结构的技术。我以前从未想过，嗯，也许这可以推广到在数据结构中寻找循环或类似的事情。我不确定它是否可以，但也许可以。是的，也许。它可以，是的，也许，也许如果你有一个算法来检测循环和某种，你知道，函数f(x)，比如想象我试图检测，比如在列表中找到一个循环，也许我的函数可以只是，你知道，前进到列表中的下一个元素？
Yeah, I guess it could, right? Like, imagine that my... Well, so that's, if you're trying to compute some kind of, like, reduction on some iterate sequence, if you detect a cycle, you can just convert it
是的，我想可以，对吧？比如，想象我的……好吧，所以，如果你试图在某个迭代序列上计算某种归约，如果你检测到一个循环，你可以直接把它转换
into some kind of, not constant time operation, but it's constant time once you find the cycle, right? Well, so I guess here's one of the applications of it. Imagine that my input is some iterator and that my transformation function just calls next on the iterator,
成某种，不是常数时间操作，但一旦你找到循环，它就是常数时间，对吧？好吧，所以我猜这是它的应用之一。想象我的输入是某个迭代器，而我的变换函数只是在迭代器上调用next，
just advances the iterator right so then i can use these step enough algorithms for detecting collision points and detecting whether something is circular and whether something is a cycle i can use that to see if there is a cycle in my whatever thing it is that I'm iterating. Right. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense.
只是推进迭代器，对吧？所以，我可以使用这些Stepanov算法来检测碰撞点，并检测某物是否是圆形的，以及它是否是一个循环。我可以使用它来查看我正在迭代的任何东西中是否存在循环。对吧。是的。是的。这有道理。
So then there's the usefulness of this. I guess I must have – maybe that's something that's obvious. It doesn't seem particularly insightful. And maybe it was just so obvious that he didn't explain that particular application or maybe it comes up in later chapters and i'm just not remembering that but it seems like this generalization of the cycle detection to just an arbitrary function it gives you the most general form of this yeah he really he really was very brilliant in his ability to get to the most generic form of something. Speaking of meetups, speaking of meetups, and this is a good segue slash closing. Well, I was going to say part four, speaking of meetups, and then we're going to get some 2025 hot takes.
所以这就是它的用处。我想我一定——也许那是显而易见的事情。它看起来并不是特别有洞察力。也许它太明显了，以至于他没有解释那个特定的应用，或者也许它出现在后面的章节中，我只是不记得了，但这种将循环检测推广到任意函数似乎给了你这种形式的最一般形式。是的，他在获得某种东西的最泛型形式的能力上确实非常出色。说到聚会，说到聚会，这是一个很好的过渡/结束。好吧，我本来想说第四部分，说到聚会，然后我们要得到一些2025年的热门观点。
I mean, technically, the time this comes out, it's going to be like mid-February. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts,
我的意思是，技术上讲，这发布的时候，大概是二月中旬。请务必在你的播客应用中或在ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、
comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is
评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是
chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
带有信息点缀的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。